sadly what do we have we have people
like me map magicians doing tricks and
psychic mediums pretending to connect
with the dead that's like our art Audrey
Armstrong fighting a sense of mystery
they're just hustlers it surrenders i
sat in a young studio audience once and
watching a psychic it was one of those
TV filmed ones where there's where
there's an audience I was just like so
before filming starts he came out and he
said so is there anybody here that's
hoping you know hoping that um someone's
gonna come through and all these hands
come up and he just asked people so well
you know what do you who you hoping will
come through okay what do they look like
is there anything because I'll let you
know if they come through is there
anything I can ask any bit of
information they could give me that
nobody could possibly know that will
prove to you it's them yes yes he he
drowned he was wearing a red sweater
okay if I want to let you know if he
comes through and then they start
filming and he just says all those
things to them and I think about the
reason why that stuff is is like people
do believe it is that the lie is so ugly
that it's so much easier to believe
something amazing must be going on there
than right is he is it just that ugly
and pathetic a lie it's such a such a
horrible experience so many of them yeah
I mean they have had television shows
were they there was a medium television
show where this woman was connecting
people with their dead relatives and it
was so fake
there's the the questions were shitty it
was so poorly thought out it wasn't just
a lie was a lively [ __ ] yeah that's a
shame there was I in one of my shows I
had I got like 50 people up on stage had
like a like an audience thing set up on
stage and I was doing mediumship with
them and providing like like very
accurate information but at the same
time saying I am you know I'm lying
right your grandmother's telling me
she's not telling me anything I'm making
this up you understand and then after
the so there's gotta be an interesting
kind of lying right right right and then
afterwards I think it was the first
night of doing the show I went out to
stage door and I was talking to people
there and there was a girl who'd seen
the show and she said will you worm I
wonder if you could put me in touch with
my dead grandmother and I said oh god
well I hope you understand from what
I've just done that I don't
I'm not really doing it that's kind of
the point [ __ ] on and I understand I
know you can't redo it but would you be
able to put me into cheese's it's an
amazing capacity for just this kind of
dissonance well that's how cults work
right yeah I mean that's the only way
they can work once you get a hold of the
manuscript and you read whatever it was
whether it's Mormonism and Joseph
Campbell the fourteen-year-old boy who
found golden tablets that contain the
lost work of Jesus only he could read
with this magic seer stone if you if you
you know if you have any critical
thinking left in you at all at that
point you just you put the book down yo
what the [ __ ] am I doing with my life
but people don't want that they want
they want the the universe is so
open-ended and the possibility of your
your existence expiring at any moment
and you just vanishing into nothingness
and this consciousness just literally
stopping the lights go black and that's
it it's so terrifying to us that we we
would prefer some nonsensical
unrealistic version of something but
rigid so we know how to follow it and a
bunch of other people follow it as well
and we have this community of people to
follow it and we gain comfort in that
and some very very